bon ça que je pense de jeu ouais c'est
vrai alors on revient à bertoua
premières crampes et à crespin
ok alors les bras vous m maillard non
bertrand rothé 2 3 soleil
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors là c'est la première fois que la
sape a commencé à tourner l'émission
avait dans sa va tout raconter qu'on le
fasse d'allécher les missions le fait
vous attendent et indirects sur d8
c'est la première fois je vous jure que
c'est vrai qu'on va faire un cache-cache
géant non
c'est pas la même chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous expliquerai je vais sortir je
vais sortir je vais compter jusqu'à 20
vous allez tous vous cacher sur le
plateau le premier j'ai compté le seul a
dit le premier que je trouve sur l'oeuf
ou d'or à temps j'ai compté là c'est
parti bannalécois merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant vous nous rejoignez sur des
mythes
c'est la première fois que bofa cascades
il y aura une émission la foutaise
émission
[Rires]
par branche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il aime bagages été trouvé j'en ai
trouvé un j'en ai trouvé alors il faut
que j'ai pour toi c'est quoi ça monte
monte monte monte monte on dit regarder
mais regardez la garde j'en ai trouvé
deux j'en ai trouvé de jean michel
lemaire trouvé c'est bon je tournais
grosjean michel mr trouver attention
attention les gars on doit rendre
l'antenne ya les inconnus après mais bon
la cabine journal tu arrives avec
derrick également il est élu quelle
heure c'est pour ça 20h38 alors attendez
je suis sûr que j'en ai vu une là j'en
ai vu une meilleure personne benhaim les
genres alors oui les google cherche gad
elmaleh gad elmaleh gad elmaleh qu'un
nom alors déjà là
connaître chaque roue et fait rouler
vers 6-7 attendait alors ensuite qu'est
ce qui nous manque si vous nous
rejoignez nous sommes emploi cache-cache
l égard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est par vidal je me suis intégré
les gars qui sait ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que les autres ou gageons que
c'est cool les autres gagner il faut
revenir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elonu manqué malades mentaux bâle ville
et au canada à cowes étonné parce qu'il
est très jeune justin j'espère qu'ils
j'ai très peur pour lui une vraie madame
ceo fully il est ok bah nan je sais pas
où aller ils m'ont pas écouté on n'a
perdu qu'à valable s'il est tellement
dans le jeu qui ne peuvent pas revenir
il a pris ce cache cache très à coeur
car adams va du rhin dans les gorges
vous lire ah oui là bas c'est surya
camille combal qui part regard sombre il
est juste là des marathons tu démarres
quand la le tournage lui
[Applaudissements]
non parce qu'ils demandent quand tu
démarres le tournoi
enfin la perception juste les gars
excusez moi il lors que madame c'est
lyon qui aura mis à l'eau la trouver
[Applaudissements]
capa
c'est très violent
et les délires avec eux j'aurais vous y
attendent ou ce qu'on veut cyril
attendus à l'hôtel squadra les valises à
l'émission c'est la seule émission
pendant l'émission il ya quelqu'un de
l'émission qui dit bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est venue mais bon j'y reviens
quand ça film salut tu restes un peu un
petit peu donne jusqu'à moi que jusqu'à
thann de ce bon bah je vais rester je
veux voir un tiguan patrik jaerbyn mais
aussi à la maison
merci merci ca lui alors on justifie je
vais juste parler avant d'aller gens
devant leur télé qui sont en train de se
dire chérie je te dis qu'ils ont fait un
cas chacun
[Applaudissements]
je dis tu te prends ce que bertrand qui
a travaillé des cocasseries qui a drainé
yannick où sont les cochons jour est
d'ailleurs redira bravo à berck ans
parce que c'était très dur de faire la
chronique au dos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]